Speaker 1: Hey, here is a story that I don't know
if you'll find this surprising. I didn't find it
particularly surprising. A new book out explains
that when Donald Trump would see staffers of color
at the White House, meaning nonwhite people, he
would assume that they were waiters, even though
they were not. There's a really good Rolling Stone
article about this, which I encourage you to check
out, which we will link to. Trump's staffers
of color at the White House and assumed they
were waiters. When Democratic leaders brought a
racially diverse group of staffers to a meeting,
the former president assumed that they were
there to serve food. Oh, my God. That is it's
absurd. But is it really that surprising? The
article recounts an event in January of 2017,
when Trump had a reception with top congressional
leaders. There were orders and there were a bunch
of Democratic staffers, and apparently Trump
turned to them and asked them to bring over
some of the appetizers. Why don't you get the
food? Trump told staffers for Chuck Schumer.
God, it's making me cringe to even read this.
Trump told staffers for Schumer, Pelosi and others
going get the food. Oof! This is according to
New York Times reporter Maggie Haberman. New book
Confidence Man. Then White House chief of Staff
Reince Priebus rushed to correct Trump's remark,
telling the then president that those were top
congressional aides, not White House wait staff.
Rolling Stone writes, Trump's remark is
just one example of Trump's casual racism,
detailed in the pages of Confidence Man. Later in
the same meeting, Trump told Schumer and Pelosi
that ballots cast by illegals were the only reason
he lost in 2016. Popular vote to Hillary. After
an awkward silence, Pelosi interjected. I don't
believe so, Mr. President. Oh, my God. This is
just wild. The book describes Trump's relationship
with Cara Young, a model he dated for many years
who had a black mother and a white father. After
meeting Young's parents, Trump joked she got her
beauty from her mother and her intelligence
from her dad. The white side. Trump laughed
at his own joke. Young didn't, and, according to
the book, voiced her displeasure. This is all just
completely nuts. It's all completely nuts, but
also completely unsurprising. Think back. Remember
this incident during Trump's 2016 campaign?
Speaker 2: We had a case where we had an
African-American guy who was a fan of mine. Great
fan. Great guy. In fact, I want to find out what's
going on with him. You know what? I look at
my African American over here. Look at him.
Are you the greatest? Do you know
what I'm talking about? Okay, so.
Speaker 1: It's funny. It's funny, but it's also
absolutely horrifying. And this shouldn't really
shock us. Remember that Donald Trump paid for
an ad in the newspaper calling for the death of
innocent black people who had been falsely accused
of a crime. It's called the Central Park Five. And
so I'm filing the revelations. And Maggie Haberman
spoke under things that we already thought were
probably true. And now we have definitive
confirmation, just completely unbelievable